it's creative strategy it's
understanding that a video on Tick Tock
is going to act different than a video
on YouTube shorts and a video on Twitter
it's you know you'll really like this
because this is there's no way to be a
big time comedian without understanding
this every platform is a different room
right right so like when you're touring
the US you're comedy is going to be
different in city by city that's right
country by country always different so
for me same with the way I do public
speaking and definitely the backbone of
why I want on social like I understand
the room that I'm in and for me it's
you're trying to get them to laugh and
think I'm trying to get them to think
and do Gary's on your Chuck thank you so
much for being here thank you for having
your sense of humor I appreciate it I
was just giving this water I imagine
this would be the last thing I drink
ah this might be the end this is okay
this is it I die in a room with toys
um thank you for for laughing and like
why don't you get mad when people make
fun of you other people get very
viciously angry but you kind of have fun
with it
um because you're this big character
yeah you say a lot of stuff I do some of
it's very funny thank you and then you
know you some people because as a
comedian our job is to we make fun of
ourselves correct we make fun of
everyone we make fun of other comedians
Joe Rogan's one of my best friends we
make fun of him and we do a dumb
imitation of him that doesn't sound like
him it's a high-pitched voice what do
you mean man it's such a stupid but he
never gets mad and you don't seem to
really get upset I think um
first of all to be very Frank I'm
flattered that yeah I'm flattered that
like that like I'm even known enough
that somebody would make jokes I think
growing up in Jersey in the 80s and 90s
is probably a big part of it I mean I
don't even recall living a life where
the majority of your friends are not
making fun of you 24 7 365 in that East
Coast 80s 90s life
um I I also love comedy like I genuinely
view it as flattering interesting you
know I I sometimes even learn from it
you're like oh it's interesting like
people are that's what they're picking
up on or like they're exaggerating that
and especially to your point when you're
a big personality and you're exaggerated
when somebody then takes the exaggerated
part of you already being exaggerated it
tends to be really funny plus I've
always thought that comedians
were incredibly smart like I just always
grew up
very much believing that like Richard
Pryor was a big factor I actually think
my keynote career is very wrestling
promo stand-up comic DNA to begin with
so I think there's a level of and
honestly to be even like really to the
point anybody who can't laugh at
themselves is [ __ ] yeah like genuinely
actually [ __ ] it means they're deeply
insecure and like unhappy and luckily
the DNA draw did not give me that and so
I'm cool with it well no and and we as
comedians it's always cool when somebody
doesn't have you killed or you have a
good amount of money and you have the
connections that's right you know what I
mean like doesn't have a car
that's nice there's nothing wrong you
know we love that Elon Musk buying
Twitter big mistake
probably not you know it's it's one of
the most important Platforms in the
world
and you know very quickly I think he
wants to turn it into something viable
uh the product you know I've been on it
for a long time I was there super early
and
I mean from 2007 to today it hasn't
really evolved a whole lot
you know obviously the guys innovated
his whole career and so you know my
Spidey senses say that he'll find Peter
I've always thought that Twitter could
be a major you know Challenger to
Netflix and Amazon Prime like the world
goes there when things are going on I've
always thought that it was a platform
that could have a subscription business
he showed that immediately he's probably
figuring out what the blue check thing
means now but like I've always thought
of it as an Ott competitor over the top
like a streaming service yeah I just
always thought there was much more that
could be done with Twitter and so I I'm
I don't think he'll lose on this one do
you think there's an issue with him
being such a big personality is there a
chance he gets in his own way a little
bit because he seems to like the
spotlight he seems to Crave the
spotlight and when you're running a
company like that is that a potential
negative
I think if
capable and you're just Sizzle and not
steak it can be a negative right
the guys run and built real companies
right so I think less likely okay you
know there's a lot of people who are
just sizzle
and they just you know let's bring it
back to Comedy yeah you and your buddies
know there's people you've come up the
game with that actually potentially were
funnier had more Raw Talent right for
sure but you knew that they weren't
willing to put in the work whether they
didn't write or they didn't they didn't
put in the [ __ ] work yeah right they
didn't do enough mics they didn't write
enough whatever you know you know this
world better than I do but I I'm
dangerous enough to keep an eye from
afar
and they haven't won
and I think that's similar to the way I
think about entrepreneurship like if you
can't actually operate if you don't put
in the work if you're not that person
the the sizzle what you're referring to
will [ __ ] it up you'll get found out
everyone gets exposed in the end right
now I'm still a believer in FTX because
I am and Sam Beckman freed I think is a
genius I'm undeterred by the new Spade
of news uh and and I just want a
commitment from you that you're still a
Believer because so many people are
jumping [ __ ] now whereas I say to myself
like isn't this time to really show him
our support like let him know that like
what he's doing is good like he's giving
Bill Clinton money and like these are
people that need money right the
Democrats yeah so it's just a good I
think it's a good thing what he's done
how do we help him that's my question
like how could we help him do we get him
to Dubai do we get him on a jet
what does this say about the larger
crypto thing is it over
no because I mean you know nobody I know
that actually is educated in crypto kept
their money in an exchange because
that's not decentralized but what about
Gisele Bundchen well that's not someone
who I would deem as somebody who's deep
crypto right you know and I think I
think some of these step backwards
during this era are going to be similar
to when pets.com and all that stuff
happened in the internet back in 2001
like people were just confused and they
get hyped and over excited about dumb
[ __ ] you know look fraud is hard to see
at times but you know centralized you
know exchanges are a dangerous game
you're keeping your money in an
unregulated Industries platform that Sam
was able to do the things that one would
fear in that scenario and so I think
crypto is such a big technology but
unfortunately greed and short-term
thinking and all that always clouds new
technologies it's always the same [ __ ]
yeah it seems to be that he was able to
win over so many well money does that
fans right money does and he was called
the Visionary is it dangerous when you
have somebody when you have a a
situation where it's the crypto in
general is not really that well
understood by the general correct right
that's right so when you have a small
amount of people that really understand
the ins and outs of this is it just more
of a uh you know potential for this type
of thing well not really because you
know the the reality is it's the people
that know it aren't necessarily even
excited about the kind of things that
are being built that are screwing things
up like the hardcore technologists
actually just wanted to all be
decentralized that's why Bitcoin has
such enthusiasm around it the nft thing
is really misunderstood because it's
about the smart contracts and the
technology there but it got all going on
the collectibility right and so I don't
think it's about a small group knowing
because it wasn't Sam's knowledge of
blockchain that created this
vulnerability it was the lack of
knowledge of people leaving their money
in there and like anything else when
people anytime there's something that's
too good to be true when everyone's
trying to make a fast Buck this is what
happens and you made the right call this
is so similar to the web in 95 678 the
difference was people weren't throwing
around money and investing in things
back then they didn't want they did on
the public stocks like the pets.com and
things that nature but that was a small
group today everybody all these
youngsters yeah they all think they're
investors yeah and they're throwing
around money like crazy so you're a
long-term believer in crypto I'm phased
by any of the uh you know obviously the
dips or
like yeah I mean I'm I'm personally most
bullish on nfts right because I think
that that's like iPhone app
website social media accounts long term
I was taught I went to Art basil last
year okay and all of the everybody was
talking about nfts yes or it might have
been two years ago I I forget probably
last year it was out of control it was
last year it was last year you had like
marshmallow at your party no okay so but
I wish I did there were some there was
some some party where somebody knew you
let me in somebody I appreciate that one
of your employees I think
um
and actually I think that we did have
yes
yeah he was good he was great
um everybody was talking about nfts yes
you have always been honest to your
credit saying 90 of these 99 99 thank
you are going away projects are going to
zero that's right is it a little insane
when do those two statements are they
able to live together like of course
that was 99 of this is going away and
yet everybody get excited about it
because it's awesome yes okay because it
was because it's the complete replica of
the internet you know most of the people
forget what internet hysteria 9678
looked like yeah and I was 10. you were
10. what did it look like it looked like
the following the internet is going to
change everything and everything's going
to be on the internet in 24 months and
meanwhile there wasn't like a person I
knew over 40 that even knew how to get
on the internet right right that's why I
get scared about the metaverse and VR
like the Techno the excitement is right
but it always takes 15 years and yes do
I think one percent is going to be
special of course I do because Amazon
was sitting there in 1999 for four
dollars a share or whatever and that was
a really good idea if you put a thousand
into Amazon it's like a million today it
like worked out the problem was people
get too greedy too fast and so yeah it
was pretty easy for me to be like hey
this nft thing's pretty awesome comma 99
of what's out right now is going to zero
don't invest money that you can't afford
to lose the problem is nobody heard the
second part right because you had a
buddy who bought a [ __ ] internet ft
that had a snail with like a cigar up
its ass and he's like I bought this for
80 bucks it's now worth 44 000 and like
everyone's like what the [ __ ] isn't that
a statement of our economy yes that a
snail with a cigar up his ass that's
right which self of like imagine telling
a uh getting a guy out of the mind all
mines in Pennsylvania and showing him
yes it it does because I I was in
subprime mortgages and and there are
people that have negative thoughts about
them yeah I think they were beautiful
instruments but a lot of people have
negative they say negative things about
them whatever but I don't think you I
think people without money should be
given it sometimes so the reality is I
don't have a problem with like these
types of speculative things where people
are like hey I'm taking a chance let's
see if this works
um but you were also a deep believer and
and this you may be proven right I don't
I don't know if we know in the art
behind some of this stuff I no for me
it's it's a couple things yeah I do
believe that there will be a Jackson
Pollock and an Andy Warhol of this
generation I believe when you and I
overbear watch this clip yeah in 22
years yeah that whether it's x copy or
people or somebody Amber Victoria I
don't know who but will there be three
to four people that put out stuff during
this era that in 25 years people collect
like vigorously yeah yes I believe that
to be true
that's point zero one percent of all the
artists right my bigger thing was I felt
what really got me hyped was it reminded
me of after school 80s cartoons if you
think about 80s after school cartoons
Transformers GI Joe My Little Pony right
yes all the Care Bears all these
Ghostbusters all these IPS were built
right and it's very clear to me that
during this era 578 GI Joe Transformer
My Little Ponies will happen because you
have real people that are real creative
that are building intellectual
properties and some of them will survive
this Carnage right and I believe that
those will be the important art
collectible cartoons video games TV
friends is your line of yes yes of all
the different and are are you you're the
proactive yes yes please yeah it looks
like you active piranha that's right so
now this is a piranha who's it believes
in Hustle culture well I don't know
about that well he's why is why is
proactive hustle culture well he's
hustling no proactive well that's a form
of hustling well it all depends on how
you want to use it so this is a piranha
and this are you against being proactive
because I would argue you're one of the
more proactive people I have actually
watched navigate Earth I well that's
completely I mean you've seen a lot of
people in that I heard that are a lot
more proactive than me you're very
proactive I try to be as proactivism
you're proactive brother I try to be
proactive which is proactive and I kind
of look like I don't want to sue you but
this is there is a similarity to this
now this this piranha is he is he to
teach children about nfts like what is
he like
is part of your here's the way I see the
V Frets yes you know everyone's going
nuts about the trans teachers like
grooming the getting the kids okay trans
icv friends as your way to groom kids
into being entrepreneurs and start
robbing their uh families why would I
rather you know what I mean just start
talking about nfts at the dinner table
like I feel like this is a way to get
into kids hands and they start talking
about blockchain at launch at school hey
on your down time would you like to join
our strategy team yeah right
well but no but I think for me you know
I think that
in a lot of stuff you talk about in a
world of red and blue right I think all
the answers are purple right really I
think it's insane what everyone's doing
and so for me V friends is kind of like
a world that I want to create that
really educates people to play a little
bit more in the middle which is like
proactiveness [ __ ] matters
accountable ant not on the Shelf talk
about a character I want to build this
is an aunt who's got [ __ ] accountable
for saying something wrong nope and
needs to be taught no this is an ant
okay that understands that almost
everybody's upset because they want to
blame somebody besides themselves so
these are characters that all have like
there's a message yes there's like
accountable and there's probably so
everyone has a thing about them yep and
is this targeted it do you think kids
learning stuff I'm gonna build it over
the next 50 years kind of like Marvel
they'll be the stuff that's young right
but then just like you know older movies
yeah
um these characters will be developed to
go the gamut from 1 to 99. okay and
right now I'm skewing towards a younger
play you know cartoons and toys and
video games and and so that's where my
focus is right now when people criticize
a lot of whatever you want to say
marketing gurus people that are telling
people like
hustle figure it out grind build your
own thing which of course is benefits to
all of that right but then there are
these these vast Chasm of inequalities
right this vast Chasm of wealth between
people that are at the top and the
people that are at the bottom and it
seems increasingly unsustainable uh that
we have this massive Chasm right is it
you mean in society not in marketing
right we're gonna probably live to see
trillionaires right right guys who have
a trillion dollars yes and then we have
large swaths of the country that are
somewhat ungovernable I mean they're
just people can't get clean water it's
it's tough how does that all in in the
way you look at the world how do you
think the ethos of what you kind of
preach fits into a society where more
and more people have less and less
and more and more people are being I
guess
disenfranchised economically they're
unable to
um participate in society in a in a way
that you would like them to yeah I mean
I think this is why I love purple versus
red and blue yeah you know I'm a true
entrepreneur right I was born in
communism right like actually right so
you know I think that I struggle with
trying to suppress Merit
agreed that's just doesn't feel like the
human Spirit agreed on the flip side the
thought of people who make hundreds of
millions of dollars a year not paying
taxes or trying to contribute feels off
as well right so for me like I'm a big
fan of the middle like I really really
believe in that [ __ ] so as far as my
message the I the the concept of like
hey here are things that I see that
might help you potentially
feels incredibly good you know I don't
think what I talk about works for
everyone I think everyone has a
different DNA like I just share the
things that I observe that I'm excited
about with the hope that it provides
value as far as kind of like just it's a
good feeling to get messages or
interactions with people that have
benefited from the positivity right
I I you know I talk to a lot of my
friends who are entrepreneurs and
capitalists who I always feel like the
world If You're Gonna Want Merit let's
have Merit and I feel like when people
get into their 70s 80s and 90s and they
don't want to fight in the jungle
anymore and they decide to use their
money to pay off politicians to keep
their money yeah that's kind of lose
your [ __ ] entrepreneurship it just
seems like the system's so easy to game
because I agree with you about Mercury I
agree so much about Merit but then you
look at the FTI stuff and you go man the
system seems very very you know easily
game well that's been you know the
problem with the FDX thing is like
Bernie Madoff did it on the SEC like it
happens all it's happened for humans are
flawed brother yeah like it's part of
the [ __ ] I know it's like it's
[ __ ] part of the game of life like it
is what it is it sucks like who like
[ __ ] ripping people off there's people
killing people this second as you and I
sit here with a [ __ ] piranha there
are people killing killing other people
humans are no money it's a waste it's
for no people doing it for free that's
right and and right that and that's a
bigger problem is that there's no even
well benefit Financial I mean if you
really want to get into like the [ __ ]
real [ __ ] up are you Ukrainian I'm
Bella Russian I was born in Belarus
what's your read on this
[ __ ] I mean I mean just quickly I know
it's hard my reading this is like you
could is there a is there a is there an
animal that'll explain the Ukraine war
behind there this is the rational
rattlesnake okay okay everything is that
really rational rattlesnake everything
that's going on in Ukraine and Russia is
not rational it's not rational not
rational it's not that rattlesnake so
but this guy he's the one who goes here
that's right I'm gonna set in a rational
rattles he likes to talk to Putin he
goes because we can't totally isolate
he's got all the news right you know
like right but and zelinski seems like
he's doing a good job and by the way as
we're filming this by the way as we're
[ __ ] taking this a [ __ ] Missile
hit Poland I know but here's the way we
all feel about Poland this may be good
for Poland but would you stop Poland has
nothing going on Gary you know this
better than anyone this is a great
Rebrand opportunity for Poland you think
so
you feel things towards Poland here's
the thing with Poland Paul is now the
country that got like hit with a missile
by mistake right it's time it's a
Rebrand it can go in it can March into
it own it otherwise we didn't really
think about Poland so this is kind of
what we have to do it's like it's
branding right you've said it so I mean
so so look I think I think the reality
is is that
there's so much always going on yeah and
right now there's a lot going on right
and this is actually why I admire what
you do for a living thank you I believe
that people need two core things when
[ __ ] is really [ __ ] tense yes one
true escapism yes and I think that's
what you provide yes I think when people
go oh really you really do yeah like
you're really good at it yeah and
[ __ ] laughing on some real [ __ ] is
something way more people need to do I
agree 100 it would really help a lot of
people there's a [ __ ] going on then
number two it's the things that I'm
passionate about which is like just kind
of jumping on what can I do about it
right you know like like if you were
just like I can't do [ __ ] everything's
[ __ ] do you know how sad you get how
fast 100 and I'm not saying that we
should do that it just by the way on the
record my number one topic for the last
25 years amongst my small group of
friends is that the separation of wealth
is the number one reason good places go
to the ground yeah and I'm completely
answer you directly people like people
go hey
um I want to hustle I want to do all
these things I want to be an
entrepreneur I want to do all these
things but like my mother has cancer yes
she does not have health care that's
real she's been working at a job for
however long and she's still unable to
pay for her medication yes these are
real things and the question becomes in
that scenario besides voting yes what
does Ronnie or Sally in that scenario do
interesting right like to me right with
like to me systematic issues yes we can
spend the rest of your [ __ ] podcast
to you and I [ __ ] die right talking
about that but then in their life they
should they could do something I I mean
here's here of course right there are
people who have remarkably challenging
circumstances that accomplish things
yeah the end right I mean they're I mean
I agree both my parents lost a parent at
5 and 16. that happened that was real
right they lived in the USSR my mom lost
her mom when did you come here 1978. so
you were born in the USSR I was born in
the U.S that's such a great hook isn't
it a great hook to have because you can
really when you say you're born in
communism you really it really is true
well you should see the combos me and my
parents have when everyone's like
America's going socialist my father is
broken you know his accents like these
[ __ ] stupid Americans if they
understood what the [ __ ] that actually
was right and so like yeah it gives you
perspective it also when you grow up in
a Russian household like when I would
like break my arm my mom would like you
remember that old Chris Rock joke that
Robitussin like rubbed like I lived that
life yeah it was like Mom I'm sick she's
like go to sleep I was like what the
[ __ ] is medicine when I was like went to
college and my friends like take some
Tylenol I'm like what is this incredible
superpower you know like she was tough
it was just different and so like so it
makes you like appreciate everything
right
do you think social media engagement is
down social media engagement is down
it's that's what all the articles are
said it's is am I wrong I think social
media engagement on certain platforms is
potentially down but go ahead
there are all these articles a spade of
Articles coming out yes this is why this
is why we're sitting here to get this
you texted me and said yeah hey this
well that's and I said brother I'm
actually going to cancel my Tuesday
night yeah let's [ __ ] hands I I was
like bring your camouflage I I want to
get your yeah I'm in my cam out this is
I want to get your read on this go ahead
there are people out there making
persuasive compelling arguments that the
your beloved social media my beloved
social media people are sick of yes
they're sick of it yes they've realized
how toxic it is yes they're gonna go
back to their regular lives whatever the
hell that means they're gonna unplug
from this thing that's good and then the
the internet is not going to be the sole
driver of culture in our our lives
anymore what is going to be Netflix I
don't know your podcast I don't know I
hope both of those things I mean deals
with both but the reality is you will
you allow this to happen
will you let this happen will you let
people you want to hear something insane
will you let people leave
do you know how pumped I would be if
social disappeared I mean that seems
crazy to hear why I [ __ ] built on
email before that or like like
I only care about where the attention is
right and I'll follow that right so like
to me if Facebook and Twitter and snap
and Tick Tock all went you know yeah
people like Tick Tock might be banned
the whole company is texting me like
what the [ __ ] I'm like good right like
it's completely irrelevant right all I
care about is trying to understand where
people are paying attention and then I
try to create value in that channel
whether that's a [ __ ] book or if I
had to go outside and [ __ ] talk on a
corner yeah I'm interested when you look
at social media and you see that it is
quite toxic well that's because people
are toxic of course they are well but
social media also allows them to be
toxic well what do you ask of amounts of
people well you want it regulated I'm
not saying regularly I'm just saying
what you like people seem to be kind of
detaching no yes I totally agree that's
good that is good I love the Merit of
the market okay if it's not bringing you
value what the [ __ ] are you doing people
come up to me all the time like
literally at the airport like Gary
Instagram I'm like like Instagram is
what's going on with this I'm like it's
just people drinking drinks out of hot
dogs and it's it's sick but don't you
understand this is kind of a portal to
Hell we've all opened here well a little
bit I don't it's a little bit of a
portal moonwalk into heaven because of
it well that's a great way to say you're
going to hell is Moon walking to Heaven
is that true that's what someone would
say if they were going to hell
if I end up in hell I'm gonna be like
[ __ ] TD if you [ __ ] send me
here you will colonize it quickly I
dominate
you would dominate I'll get everybody
happy yeah
so what is the main focus of when you
look at these people saying that the
internet's people are kind of getting
you know take stepping back it means
nothing new in fact you like it you
think this is a good thing I think these
are articles being written based on the
the article that you're probably
referring to is like oh it's more about
Tick Tock and YouTube and like Netflix
it's more about entertainment and I'm
like who's providing the entertainment
right it's humans yeah like I I love
this concept yeah that like nothing look
any ideology one has yeah just no matter
where it is right you just have to base
it on what people are actually doing
does does the I'm gonna tell you let me
just finish this for sure people are not
using this [ __ ] less right but if they
are cool if there's a fat girl on
Instagram who eats a different sausage
every day yes does she deserve to be
famous do you know what I mean anybody
deserves this but Gary don't you see why
some people think that's crazy I think
it's crazy that you and you and I are
famous I don't even know if we are but
you're very famous
after you I don't have you you go to
[ __ ] Australia and fill out [ __ ]
Arenas that's you well the people in
Australia have been very kind and good
okay they're very very nice yes yes I've
said horrible things about them I
actually think that there is no Fame
it's been commoditized and everybody's
got some sort of audience right I think
it's awesome I think it's awesome that
Sean can do what he does with comedy on
people that that who is Russia what does
Sean do Sean is going to be as big as
you in three years that's I let's see
should be bigger than me now but what
does he do just out of curiosity he
works at 1 37 PM which is a media
platform that I own here in my Vayner X
World okay but really he's a future
comedic Superstar wow I really think
he's very tell I really do think he's
extremely talented God bless good luck
thank you and I think you if you dug in
would like actually believe that's true
I I feel like he's part of the crew that
you came up with like you would see it
anyway nonetheless
first very briefly but we didn't know oh
you want this gang fast yeah okay
he's plugged in like like by the way
I just said that strictly selfish so I
could cut it in four years and like I
predicted this kid right that was all
selfish that's what you do do you are
you doing knowing that it's all of it
there's something are they what are they
the other tests all of it because uh
yeah if you're listening right now the
building is doing a test that's good
it's authentic
um
everything I am petrified to be wrong
right so everything I say publicly I'd
like to be right about Sam Bachman freed
calls you what do you tell him what's
your advice to a guy at this point in
his life he's a young guy I am believe
it or not you'll appreciate this I have
followed this so little it is very
seemingly that he's in fraudsville and I
think what he needs to do is like really
go through like some help to understand
how he got into this place into
fraudsville yeah so we he's got to maybe
get some therapy to get into fraudsville
I think so better help online therapy
will do it
um I I'm sure so your company because
there's people out there that don't
understand what you do right that's
right no it's true they go wait wait
he's there he's everywhere but we don't
understand what he does have you watched
the
show Mad Men yes that's what I do for a
living a very large version of the
advertising Giants that you're helping
companies connect with people on social
media yeah but also I mean how my social
media get better not yours because I'm
not big enough but no no but like that's
correct not people right
yes companies It's Cold Stone Creamery I
would love to could come to you yes and
say we need more fat sad people to come
and you are establishments that we put
why does it have to be fat and sad
because that's where you build your
Market Gary no there's there's kids and
families every now and then after little
game but you build your Market if it
cold stone on a guy who's had enough who
comes in and just wants do you like Cold
Stone like it's not bad it's good right
it's not bad I've been fat and sad and
I'm telling you there there are markets
that are built on on the backs of of sad
people that are doing the wrong thing
there's nothing wrong with that I
understand yes you have to connect with
everybody you know so but those so
companies are for you it's not people
correct okay interesting and so for me
these companies waste so much money on
traditional TV commercials banner ads on
websites it's actually scary how poorly
The Fortune 500 ecosystem spends their
marketing dollars and so we came 13
years ago and have really built a large
2 000 person global company that I'm
really proud of and I really enjoy
operating who are the most interesting
entrepreneurs that you've seen up close
that you've worked with that you think
are I don't know how many of them you
can say or not that you look at and they
embody the values of somebody who can
really uh you know innovate and change
the world like who are the people that
I'm a big fan I'm a big fan of Evan
Williams he was Jack dorsey's partner at
Twitter okay he did um blogger blogger
back in the day and then he did audio
which was a podcast thing that kind of
got crushed because Apple came out with
right it's iTunes and then he did
Twitter with Jack and he was
instrumental he was the first CEO I
believe I've always thought you know
what do you think of Jack I Don't Know
Jack super well but like he really
invented the concept of Twitter right
and I loved that he was running Twitter
outfits where he dresses like a shaman
he's cool yeah no that's disturbing oh
it's disturbing well it's a little
off-putting it's but I get it it's cool
for a minute but then it gets odd but
but these guys are interesting they're
unique eccentric people
Evan is super not okay I think what Evan
is is just very in tune with consumers I
really like people that really Sarah
Blakely with Spanx okay if you really
look at how she built that brand right
very in tune with cons like what I get
excited about is when people really have
a good sense of what the masses want
okay I'm intrigued by that like truly
being like hey this is missing or this
would be awesome if it existed right and
it doesn't have to be something as
profound as like what Elon and like and
Jack and like it could be literally
Spanx it could literally be like you
know like like who thought of like
bottled water like like I actually think
that's interesting it would have been a
ridiculous concept it was [ __ ] free
somebody's like no people will actually
want this this way I'm always fascinated
by that are you fascinated by this and
I'm sure you are about like you know you
look at casamigos tequila look at what
the Kardashians yes all this influencer
Capital right celebrity Capital where
it's like their value is In Their
audience their name things like that
that's a very interesting they're
partnering with you know it's funny I
also grew up in the liquor industry my
dad had a liquor store and what I will
tell you is
what people don't know about Ryan
Reynolds gin right or the rocks or
cloonis tequila is what they've a lot of
these celebrities have done
well is they've actually made really
good products so what used to happen in
especially alcohol is like the Rolling
Stones would like give their name to a
wine it would be like bulk [ __ ] wine
and it was like a novelty gift somewhere
around 20 years ago people started
getting serious and making like actual
good stuff right so now what I think is
fascinating about that whole genre is
they're not mailing it in on the product
and I think it's a preview of what
you're going to see more and more which
is like it's not a private label that
just puts a celebrity on it which was
the whole move of the 80s and 90s people
are trying to build actual things and I
do think people like Mr Beast and others
are going to build multi-billion dollar
companies you you should Mr B seems to
be like the guy he's doing a really good
job yeah I mean he's also like you know
like he goes more into your world where
like when I think about you when I think
about like there's people that have
craft yeah his videos on YouTube is crap
brilliant like my craft is just the
words and ideas that come out of my
mouth but it's not the production and
like like he is craft yeah and you know
the Beast Burger thing has been huge the
chocolate thing's been huge she's a
young dude he understands like giving a
[ __ ] about your audience playing the
long game he's been patient who are your
competitors who are the people who are
the people out there do you have enemies
do you have people you want to crush is
it like succession where you sit back
here and you go there's another I think
Dad and I want his family I did I think
that's where people have a real [ __ ]
up view of the world the the world is
fundamentally abundant there's nobody
that's taking any fans from you right
like there's plenty of comedians they're
all over the streaming services it's a
Renaissance for all you guys and gals
it's awesome but I promise you the seven
to ten people that are in the game that
you look at that you admire that you
think are good that are bad whatever
none of them are taking anything from
you no and and what Joe Rogan has done
is kind of shown people that by sharing
correct
doing all that stuff you actually help
each other help yourself so you're 100
right I look do I want to win of course
I'm competitive I like to be as
successful as I can be at the game that
I'm playing but like as a Jets fan yeah
when the Jets lose a football game and
the game's over and they take their
helmets off and they're giving love to
the opponent I hate that right because
I'm pissed right because I'm a fan right
fanatic yeah and I want to [ __ ] punch
the TV because I'm like [ __ ] those guys
don't even shake their hands right but
when I do it in real life
AKA pitching for business and we lose it
like I'm not angry about that I don't
think anyone's taking anything from me
yeah and so like I don't I don't really
have a feeling where I have negative
feelings towards people I want to win
every time but if not cool and I'm
definitely not gonna be like Sally or
Rick or pieces of [ __ ] because they slip
out on the staff Everett do you give
those meetings do you give those like uh
you know like uh Glenn Gary Glenn Ross
meetings where it's like always be
closing I think the concept of leading
with fear is [ __ ] asinine right no I
do not do that okay so you're more of
like a kind of like uh I don't know how
what you would say but more of like a
lover a lover yeah okay so you're not
Logan Roy you're not going in there and
like okay do you what are you when you
when you first started making money what
were the things that you liked was it a
nice car was it a watch was it are you
into stuff like that or was it I don't
like stuff I I did like buying like
custom Jets jerseys of like random
players that nobody knew who the [ __ ]
they were okay but that's like ninety
dollars right I don't really like to buy
stuff I do like vacations I like
spending time with my friends and family
right like I'm huge that to me is
humongous I'd much rather spend on like
paying for like my family's flights or
[ __ ] like that that's the big luxury
place for me right so it's not things I
don't want things it's experiences I
want the game right experiences yes
you want the game you like the game you
just like I'm just curious how great of
an entrepreneur am I is a question I'd
like answered for myself before I die
that's a very interesting question how
great of an entrepreneur because since
you're a little kid you just love making
making businesses making money making
things happen yes and you want to take
that as far as you can take it I'm
genuinely curious
of how great am I at the game of
business right on the flip side in
parallel I love you know I love the game
so much that I want to give back to it
back to Joe that you mentioned yeah I'm
a I really [ __ ] with comedians yeah I
really do and I'll tell you why
I love the following scenario when I
watch documentaries and I watch a lot of
[ __ ] I always collecting I always love
hearing all of you guys and gals talk
about when you had a set at the Laugh
Factory and a [ __ ] OG came up to you
and gave you dabs yeah
I've always been very fascinated by that
like just the concept of people at the
top of the game loving their game so
much that they're willing to give love
for the kids that are on the come up
yeah and I do a ton of that in
entrepreneur land I want to leave a
legacy that brings value to the other
people trying to play this game how do
people get jobs at Fan your media do
that how does it do you see someone
doing something in life do you ever go
you're at a restaurant and you see a guy
who's just the best waiter yes the best
bartender and you go listen dude you
that was very common at Vayner early on
it's less common now because I just
haven't been out and about the last
three years because of covet and I'm not
traveling as much right
and at this point we're just getting
bombarded with hundreds of applications
a week right like these guys that are in
the room right now they all have a
similar look to them they haven't it's
an intensity that's terrifying yes and
you can tell it behind their eyes
there's nothing and you could just and
they're ready to kill you personally
anymore there's trees just being chopped
down in there yes and and but there's
something about that I think is good
like I look at these people and I go
these are good people how do you find
them I think it becomes momentum like a
lot of it's Word of Mouth a lot of it's
random Dustin get on the mic real quick
and yeah get close how did you get your
job Dustin tell us I applied like a
regular person and what happened got
rejected we could say it into the mic
just because we want the people to know
got applied applied toys got rejected
both times
um then
you kidnap Gary's children it's smart
it's a good I wish it was that easy but
um then the director at the time just
hit me up an email said come in for an
interview I said okay cool had the
interview gave me a homework assignment
did the homework assignments never heard
from him again then four months later
calls me out of the blue and was like
hey you still interested in the job I
said yes come in uh let's I mean we'll
see we'll go from there and then just
Sean went hard from then um
our well I I applied twice yep and
didn't hear back started popping off on
Tick Tock a little bit right yeah well
then I I stopped because I was upset
about a girl and I had a lull in my life
and then may hit me up
okay we love yourself will you edit Gary
stick talks so wow do you ever see it in
the interview not and you're
intimidating no no don't come in no I
think I I do at the most my direct
reports the c-suite and things of that
nature I used to sweet as the top
this is the top this is the top you
don't get to the c-suite without
competence
yeah confidence probably competence oh
competition I'm guessing Okay that you
have competence that's a good point you
know the reality is hiring is guessing
right like I really go on my intuition
you know it's funny you said early on
the way we started this I'm so confident
in my intuition
that that's why I think I do so well
with people razzing me or making sure
like literally the first time I ever saw
any of the stuff that you were saying
right I had already been aware of some
of your comedy and then saw this some of
the stuff it was within a hundredth of a
second I'm like this is a good dude
right it didn't even cry like while all
my friends were like yo we're gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of TV no no no no no I'm
like he's a great dude they're like what
all right you know the trees in the eyes
like that yeah you know so for me the
same thing with hiring comma I've
mishired so much in my [ __ ] life
right that I know it's [ __ ] guessing
it's guess it's [ __ ] guessing right
of course you get more experiences you
get the great [ __ ] Heroes no
different than your sets are stronger
today than 15 years ago yeah but every
[ __ ] I mean I I've made a couple hires
in the last 18 months literally I'm just
laughing at how bad these people are
right now yeah what makes somebody great
as an employee or not you know somebody
who's like what makes somebody better in
the business situation and what makes
somebody worse like is it somebody who's
able to stop at the door Yeah in our
company it's not being it's not
believing in cynicism and not being
scared okay because we have unlimited
doors my doors open are people team is
huge like the way we do HR is [ __ ]
different and like if you're gonna bring
cynicism of the places you worked in the
past it's going to lead to politics and
you're going to lose if you're willing
to kind of let go and over communicate
whatever's bothering you or things that
nature you will crush yeah when you're
telling companies how to reach people
yes what's the most important you know
you know they go we want to get to
Consumers creative strategy per social
media platforms okay understanding like
for you for example yeah back to your
social yes I would do a lot more on
LinkedIn if I were you I you know what
this is brilliant because I've never
thought about that so I think a lot of
your comedy is super thoughtful no and I
didn't even know I could do something on
LinkedIn correct do you mean comedy or
start like a healthcare fraud company
because I'll do that I know you will
okay but I highly recommend you get
thoughtful about taking some of your
Clips yeah clipping it for LinkedIn and
writing copy that is a hair take like 10
miles off your fastball yeah and I think
you would [ __ ] Crush that's very
interesting so it's it's creative
strategy it's understanding that a video
on Tick Tock is going to act different
than a video on YouTube shorts and a
video on Twitter it's you know you'll
really like this because this is there's
no way to be a big time comedian without
understanding this every platform is a
different room right right so like when
you're touring the U.S yes you know I
know this about your comedy because I've
as I've dug in as we've gotten friendly
on text a little bit I like am more
Curious and I'm always kind of rooting
more you have to know somebody your your
comedy is going to be different in city
by city that's right country by country
always different so for me same with the
way I do public speaking and definitely
the backbone of why I want on social
like I understand the room that I'm in
and for me it's you're trying to get
them to laugh and think I'm trying to
get them to think and do right and so I
think that's where people are missing
they think let me make a piece of
content and I'm going to blast it on all
these platforms I'm thinking oh I'm in
Tick Tock tonight well I'm in like
Buffalo for 40 people I have to give us
I have to give a Josh Allen joke right
oh I'm in Australia let me give a footy
joke right and a Cooper's beer not a
Budweiser and so contextual creative is
the number like out of this entire
podcast for all the people listening
this little part right here is the
single thing that can make their career
or their little business or their big
business go further understanding how to
make content for the place you're
[ __ ] Distributing it right
what do you think about the Resurgence
of nfts when does that happen I have no
idea you have no idea no because now
you're in the winter
we are in crypto winter this is the
death this is when this is this is when
B Players Get Smoked Out B players yeah
the C and dnf players are literally
already gone they're dead they're dead B
players are gonna get the frostbite and
get their toes cut out how bad has it
gotten what's a crypto Punk going for
now maybe the floor is like
8 70 80k and it was five horrible well
crypto punks is the one because that guy
that's gonna be the one yeah like you
know I can only talk about what I'm
doing that's the only one I'm sure of
including mine If I Die Tomorrow V
friends can't be what it was supposed to
be right from V friends to World of
women to board ape to all of them yeah
it requires the operator to make it
awesome over the next 20 years to
justify the whole thing you said every
business is gonna eventually have an nft
strategy of course 100 you said well
three is going it's an inevitable thing
correct it's gonna happen yes
um and you don't know when well I think
over the next decade or two that will be
obvious and here's what I mean by that
almost every every like the amount of
companies that have an app on the iPhone
is remarkable right there's like local
pizza restaurants that have one location
in Maine that have an app right not
every single app is going to become
Tick-Tock and Instagram
same with nfts the technology of nft is
going to work for every business
but not every project is going to be
board API club right so it's technology
not about the collectibility
when do you think the metaverse
because the metaverse those things look
horrible are you excited on some real
[ __ ] real [ __ ] because you're a smart
dude sure are you excited about doing
virtual events in 15 years I kind of am
yeah I I think you're gonna Crush that
yes I I I'm excited about that and what
are you where are you gonna live full
time when you don't have to go anywhere
according to the IRS I file in Dubai
right taxes in Dubai and I and I have a
mosque where I run most of my business
through no but real talk yeah what's
your get what's your absolute guess just
for fun so we can recall it and clip it
and see how right you are okay 16 years
from now yes VR is at full scale yes you
don't have to go anywhere okay you are
gonna have a home base and you're gonna
do 200 shows a year yeah and you're not
gonna [ __ ] travel interesting where
do you physically live in the middle of
the ocean
in like a in like a pot like a pirate
like a pod what do you think about
Austin Texas everyone's saying it's the
next thing everybody's going to Austin
are you going to be left behind living
in New York like some loser look at this
dump have you been to Austin have you
seen it they have a barbecue and
lesbians don't you want to go there and
we have barbecue we have barbecues and
lesbians anymore no I know but what do
you say now we all know Austin's a dump
and the people who are moving there are
insane but what do you think about it
where do you stand on it are you with
them are you against them I'm with
everyone
you're with everybody you can't because
of course you can you can't be with
everyone I'm I'm never live in Austin
Texas 100 now never never and now why
because I'll never leave New York okay I
would never live in L.A I would never
live in Detroit I would love never live
in Florida what do you think it is about
New York for you specifically the New
York Jets
is that it yes is that true yes that's
decision I need to be thank God you do
this because you really could have been
a killer you could have killed it you
really could like as I sit here into
this interview it's like thank God you
were an entrepreneur because there
there's another version of you that's
just killing you did I just you love the
Jets I love the Jets see I it's funny to
me because I used to be a tour guide on
a double decker bus before I had any
money doing comedy and there was one guy
named Bernie who was this guy he was
this older guy he never he was always
like I don't have any money I live in
the Bronx it's horrible and I go why
don't you move you know they have tour
buses other places Yankees and he I
swear to God he went I like the Yankees
and I'm like yeah
it's insane that was the only other time
you heard somebody this insane yeah I
heard it here in this Colossus
and then Bernie the tour guide is
probably God Rest his son I imagine he's
dead Bernie I hope you're alive if you
are please hit us up DLS
um I this is the place man it's
obviously the Jets but like this is the
place where else why right like it's got
everything there's so many people I love
people it's got so many people it's
always crowded yeah it's always Austin
has tacos that you can eat in the
morning they call them breakfast tacos
we have those big there's nothing
anybody has yeah that we don't have
well okay
if you say no of course I know that
you're correct I mean I moved to LA
because yeah you know because you're an
entertainment that's where the devil
yeah that's where you want to be and in
my business you have to get as close as
you can to the devil before he eats your
soul and then spits you out now that's
kind of what our business is that's what
the entertainment and then you always
want to do it
uh meet the devil no did I yeah when I
was a little kid I was funny and my
parents you know I lived a cut a crazy
life and it was uh I did drugs early and
I was uh precocious and I liked adults I
liked hearing adult conversations when I
was a kid I liked people that were
sarcastic and rude and cynical and all
the things that became funny I like
people that were like smoke cigarettes
outside and like [ __ ] this and I was
withdrawn to it I was drawn to it I
always thought that was kind of funny
like the guy at the dinner who would say
you know uh you know like I just
remember like hearing like when I was a
little kid like uh you know my mother's
friend was outside the house and like
I think she was like smoking a cigarette
and she was like oh she was talking
about somebody she's like total piece of
[ __ ] and I was like I want to do that
for a living like it was just funny
there was something funny and free yeah
about uh the way people chose to look at
the world because there is so much
horror and there was so much sadness yes
and like you said I I'm not a communist
so I know you'll never alleviate all of
it yeah like all the utopians go we can
alleviate all that you want so the
reality is you do get to a point where
you go if you can look at and frame
things in a funny way yeah you're
talking about perspective yeah
perspective I I absolutely believe it's
funny we got here I would have been
really pissed if we didn't touch on this
exact thing yeah I think it's the whole
game I actually think you and I
I mean that's crazy let me explain I
mean it could be true I actually think
this is why we have a nice kinship I
think Sam bankman Freedom me are the
same yeah fair enough but I'm telling
you I think this is why we have a little
bit of a kinship yes I think the way you
just frame that is exactly how I live my
life right which is you do it from a
framework of and so I touched on it
earlier of like hey it's heavy let's
decide to look at it like this and smile
about it a little bit and maybe think a
little bit and it might lead to
something yes and I genuinely think the
same thing like literally everything I
believe in is like okay and now what
yeah everything is and now what should I
come out with a line of V French should
I have like racist Rhino where it's like
a rhino who's just like a product of his
time he's a product of his time he's not
he's no money it's just 1957 that's not
malicious it was 1957. he just doesn't
know what he doesn't know I mean
um do you tend to view the future of
technology with all pot you have very
rose colored glasses which I think so
but I think I'm practicable some dark
things coming with the tech right
there's you know I love when people are
like deck [ __ ] everything up I'm like
I was like do you remember Hitler like
like do you remember imagine Hitler now
yeah what about him it'd be probably
worse would it or would it or what if he
not gotten that far great point like I
would argue that there's no shot he got
that far right because the information
would have flowed too fast as a comic
too I think it's specifically hard
for
uh people that are you know
you know you know that engage in things
like satire sarcasm yeah I did engage in
like things that you know are tougher to
read on social media because you don't
hear my voice it's not a live show
you're not you know so you're you're
irony all these things kind of can get
lost the lucky thing is that I actually
believe back to my rosy colored glasses
I do think that people understand intent
I would argue that what's really hurting
a lot of people who are very quick to
cancel is that they're completely tone
deaf to intent thus rendering it very
difficult to have it be palpable to
human beings right when you're just like
[ __ ] that person you're like it's so
[ __ ] clear that that person is
tongue-in-cheeking this and so like
that's where people really struggle when
we take away intent and context from the
conversation that's why we're challenged
right now how much do you travel for
your job are you all over the place I
mean before covet all over the place
yeah we have offices in London and
Singapore and la and Mexico City have
you slowed down yes will you ever slow
down yeah okay yeah look I'm I'm simple
bro yeah I'm [ __ ] simple
like I'm high energy and I'm pumped and
I'm excited and passionate but like
none of this [ __ ] [ __ ] matters right
like honestly right like like back to
the how this [ __ ] show started why
are you not upset because I don't think
I mean anything right people are [ __ ]
confused well you know what's important
your family yeah right right exactly
like [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] like the
reason people get upset is because they
think there's somebody and I tell people
like did you see what happened to prince
prince really [ __ ] culturally meant
something right poor guy passes yeah we
[ __ ] are all hurt we give them 24
hours of flowers and then a week later
the world's spinning right
everyone's walking around getting
offended as if they mean something if
you're if you a guy like Trump right his
company's had some interesting things
yes what's your advice to the Trump
brand what does the Trump brand do right
now how do they turn it around
I don't you know that's so complicated
it is but because it's a guy to tell
them
listen yes the opening question I ask
everybody is what would you like to
accomplish they want to uh keep having
money and get the feds off their back
I I think that ship has sailed you know
what I mean like that goes back like
every time somebody comes into this
office I'm like what would you like to
happen
and I always tell them like good
marketing just speeds up everyone
finding out the truth about your product
right
back to when you said social media right
like everyone's like social media I'm
like so should we expose this
it speeds up the exposure of
interesting it doesn't change everyone's
like it's doing all this [ __ ] the
algorithm the algorithm is responding to
you they want to sell ads right they
want to [ __ ] sell ads right no
different than Seinfeld you know why
Seinfeld got paid a [ __ ] fortune by
NBC they sold [ __ ] ads right if
you're looking at cars all day long and
searching cars you'll get your [ __ ]
cars and your content right like
everyone like they love people love this
people love this idea of a Wizard of Oz
Mark Zuckerberg is not sitting at
[ __ ] home being like Oh Ricky
Thompson the 16 year old I'm gonna send
him some poison now it's so [ __ ]
delusional right all right you know what
you should start talking more about that
will land yes instead of people blaming
platforms why don't we start having a
more modern conversation about parenting
I Believe by the way 100 I'm with you
there let's go my man let's team maybe
we should go on a tour yes
and just [ __ ] talk about it but there
are good parents there's unlimited good
parents Caitlyn Jenner and the other one
because what they did this guy was they
what's what's her name uh Chris because
what they did Chris and Caitlin
um is they made their family a business
into a multi-billion dollar business
that's cheapened and destroyed uh and
hasted the demise of uh Earth that's
good and I think his parents that's good
you know what's interesting
plastic surgery they look nice I've got
a hot take for you on that one yeah a
counter take yes it's insane how much
those siblings love each other I I how
about that how about curveball if all of
my siblings or billionaires do you know
how much I'd love them
do you have any idea how much I love
them if our love was commodified I'm
incredible I'm incredibly impressed
about that for him I've said she should
be the governor of California I think
she's a hard worker will you be a
governor I think so I might run for
something yeah you're going to it might
you see it right sure you agree I wish I
should do it I can't be president so I'm
out
well you could help me I would help you
and we could figure out a way to do it
I'm telling you right now the other day
maybe I should run for something I'm
telling you right if I don't win it'd be
a great no different than you texted me
and said hey social media is dead you
want to do the show and boom was I there
you were here I [ __ ] changed my plans
got here today in nine years when you
text me and be like yo I want to be the
governor of Kansas yeah I will be right
there
we have to start a cancer yeah I want
you in Kansas City I want you in Canada
that's horrible why because it's rough
out there but then you could kind of do
what you want no Kansas is awesome you
could kill Kansas is awesome you don't
think Kansas is awesome Kansas would
make me live in Austin
what do you think is going on with Miami
all right hold on I just gotta make sure
okay yeah go ahead Miami I like it down
there it's warm Coke Paradise the future
of crypto the crypto Hub What's it gonna
be a lot of tech people my favorite
thing about Miami is that all my new all
my New York buddies who move down there
yeah and claimed that they were going to
be their post covet are back are back
and I won a lot of side Bets with all of
them that's interesting they're
delusioned that they were actually going
to be entertained enough and stimulated
enough to actually live there full time
was so funny to me that they didn't
understand that one day kovid would be
over and you actually would have New
York back to New York
right and I I was fascinated by people's
delusion on that yeah Miami is a great
place to visit and that's Austin it's
all of them right
that's just a great they're actually
listen Austin Miami these are great
cities but compared to [ __ ] New York
you can't it's like dog [ __ ] what do you
think of L.A you think it's a dump I
Don't Love L.A but but
I love I mean I like how again if let me
take a big step back every place besides
Boston because they have the Patriots is
lovely okay
none of them are even in the [ __ ]
Stratosphere of New York City right so
none of them are either it really is
it's the greatest city in the world so
I'm always going to be new yorked out
when I say that but all these places are
awesome now are you a guy that before
you go to bed every night House of card
style puts on a hoodie and just throws
someone in front of a train no just to
sleep at night just because it's do you
get off on that kind of energy do you
sleep easy
sometimes I sleep like a I literally am
out like a light yeah don't wake up at
all occasionally once in a blue moon
needs to drink water never have to piss
straight eight hours seven hours yeah
out no stress one last piece of advice
because by the way I do I want to thank
you for doing this I really appreciate
it happy to do it one last piece of
advice for all of the people right now
that have an idea that they really
believe in and it hasn't worked and it
hasn't worked out it hasn't worked
understand that one there's a couple
things one it might be timing you just
might be too early or too late timing's
a real thing two you might not be good
at executing your idea and it might be a
good idea to bring a partner in to help
you do it okay right like like it's okay
50 of something meaningful is a [ __ ]
load better than 100 of nothing right
and so I think humility is like a huge
huge factor in all this yeah and so if
it hasn't happened yet timing maybe you
need more patience or look yourself in
the mirror and be like hey I'm good at
the idea but I can't [ __ ] make it
come true let me go find somebody that
can
Sam bankman free if you're listening I
want you to say that to yourself in the
mirror right now because me Gary
vaynerchuk support you and love you and
we want you back we want you back as
soon as possible and to because it's a
great idea whatever it was the crypto
exchange and just come back we love you
Gary thank you thank you brother good
appreciate it thank you thank you thank
you buddy I appreciate it that was fun
it was a blast okay good
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]